بدات ثوره
الذكاء الاصطناعي تقلق البعض حول مستقبل
وظائفهم خصوصا في القطاعات الماليه
والتكنولوجيه ورغم ذلك اظهر مسح البلومبرج
حول القطاعات المتوقعه ان تتاثر بالذكاء
الاصطناعي ان الذين يعملون بشكل اساسي في
القطاع المالي لا يرون ان وظائفهم ستكون
معارضه للخطر في المستقبل القريب وفقا
لنحو ثلثي المشاركين البالغ عددهم 292
شخصا وجد الاستطلاع ايضا ان غالبيه
المشاركين لا يستخدمون او يخططون لاستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي في وظائفهم حيث قال 12%
فقط انهم يستخدمون الذكاء الاصطناعي فيما
يخطط 27% منهم لذلك الفكره هنا ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يبني قدراته على البيانات
والمعلومات التاريخيه وما زال من الصعب ان
يتوقع بشكل دقيق الاحداث لمستقبليه وتعتمد
ذاكرته على ما تم تحميله من معلومات
وبالتالي قد يظهر توقعات منحازه بناء على
البيانات التاريخيه ذلك لا يرى
الاقتصاديون والمحللون الماليون تخوفا
كبيرا من ان تستبدلهم تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي بسهوله بالمقابل يبدو ان التخوف
اكبر في قطاعات التكنولوجيا حيث بدات
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل
استبدال اعمال كثيره للمبرمجين وتقنيين
يقومون باعمال مكرره وفي الاونه الاخيره
بدات شركات عملاقه مثل مايكروسوفت وامازون
وماتا في الغاء الاف الوظائف حيث يتم
استبدال الكثير منهم بالاستعانه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي وانتم ما رايكم بهذا التحول
السريع هل ترون مخاطر على وظائفكم